le remake n'a qu'à 45 mais je crois la
chaise comme beau gosse un peu on va
voir non ça y est c'est bon ça a l'air
de marcher c'est moi qui avait des
soucis probablement ma connexion infable
qui est pas toujours parfaite
possible je n'étais pas là je sais pas
j'ai pas vu
et donc ouais ben écoute nouvelle finale
Naka cardsen du coup
qui devra battre deux fois Magnus en
match s'il veut gagner ce temps là
donc ça va être dur peut-être qu'il va
d'ailleurs finir le tournoi vaincu
possible vraiment bien ce système de
laisser plusieurs vies de faire des
remakes de match ça permet de voir plus
quoi voilà ah non mais si tu en avais
pas assez de makakar le sel je pense que
tu vas en avoir ouais comme tu disais
peut-être une dizaine de matchs
et ça fait quand même ça fait plaisir
c'est toujours des beaux classico pour
un peu qui te organisent un match entre
eux en plus
un supplémentaire
on va voir on va on va attendre pour le
cadrage des cames parce qu'il y a
plusieurs divisions à division 2
divisions 3 et elle est repêchage des
divisions c'est
à mon avis il y avait la finale de la
division 2 avant que nous on a pas suivi
mais qu'on aurait pu suivre parce que
bon c'est quand même c'était quand même
une deuxième division
et ça aurait pu
c'est karena qu'on dit Yong division qui
doit se terminer maintenant et donc là
nous on va suivre la finale de la
première division par la suite
extraordinaire
je crois qu'il y a pas besoin de la 4e
partie du coup
normalement ils jouent en 7 je sais pas
les règles mais
blanc d'accord
que les deux autres partent parce que
sinon je vais cadrer maintenant
on va aller dans le dans le truc sans
cadrage et toi voilà sans tête de toute
façon ça apporte pas grand chose non
plus on va pas se mentir
et une fois que les deux seront partis
on va passer 10 minutes à cadrer d'un
côté et on va devoir recadrer ce qu'on
est cadré de l'autre et en plus de toute
façon il joue pas donc
partant de là
on va on va un peu temporiser
on va se sucer un Fab
de toute façon tu vois ça joue pas
donc c'est pas c'est pas très très grave
Magnus va le broyeuse on verra de toute
façon on est là pour voir c'est un
remake de l'autre match ça ça reprend
donc c'est quatre qu'il avait pas joué
ça l'autre fois
ces quatre qui est F3 alors plutôt aussi
si ko normalement et sur des quatre fou
B4 il peut refaire son C5 alors non
autre Cooke et c'est 3
OK et je m'attends à des 5 donc
une dragosine
il peut son nouveau répertoire
parce que font karwana et en fait dans
le truc
branchée donc ça c'est un autre c'est
pas pourri il joue mais
mais on est d'accord que leur match est
fini en division 2 moi qui est de 7 moi
j'en sais rien ou qui joue en 10 parties
en winner cute
alors attend du coup je vais je vais
cadrer le truc attendez 2 secondes parce
que ouais il peut
oui ça c'est très possible en fait
parce que c'est ça la spécifier ce
format j'ai envie de dire ça qui est
vraiment beau c'est que si Naka gagne ce
match un deuxième match puisque puisque
Carlsen a encore deux vies
donc oui
et c'est ça tout le toute la beauté du
format entre guillemets disons Magnus là
ne peut pas être éliminé ne peut pas
perdre par contre
IKA ou peut c'est ça c'est un premier
match ouais bien sûr à mon avis c'est
Carlson c'est
Ikao qui va gagner ce match
mais qui gagnera au final je sais pas
mais à mon avis qui arrive à gagner ce
match en 4 donc pour le scénario c'est
mieux quoi
après
j'en sais rien
et du coup c'est pas Armageddon c'est la
finale bien remettre
voilà on est bien
[Musique]
douteuse mais en fait c'est plus ou
moins correctement
donc au lieu de jouer 7 il a pris en C4
et c'est la fameuse variante où on joue
B5 pour défendre le pion mais on laisse
B5 après bah c'est énorme bizarre mais
ça va du coup on n'a pas de purement
encore mais ces quatre est faible mais
au moins le fou va s'activer vers B7 on
a une bonne case en dessin qui
éventuellement les petites pressions sur
sur des 4
c'est un truc que ouais je vais regarder
il y a quelques années de ça mais que
j'ai jamais joué je sais pas
j'avais pas super confiance en la
position
ouais mais ça va ouais je sais enfin de
toute façon j'avais vu avec l'ordi et
j'ai pas de fuite mais souvenir de trucs
ouais mais ça peut se retourner devenir
dangereux non non c'est une bonne arme
c'est intéressant
non parce qu'en fait du coup Carlson
passera en loser bracket en quelque
sorte et Naka lui il est déjà en looser
enfin ouais c'est en gros tu as deux
vies en fait c'est un double élimination
donc là c'est la c'est la double finale
entre guillemets
théoriquement on peut avoir jusqu'à 8
parties aujourd'hui puisqu'on peut avoir
quatre parties de la finale plus
l'Armageddon donc ça en fer 5 2 + 2
parties de la deuxième finale qui serait
du coup en deux parties tu pourrais
faire du aussi
erreur
c'est le scénario rêvé Fab ouais
[Musique]
c'est possible ça peut finir en 8 nul on
espère Victor nakar magazon match de
victoire et Magnus à la maison Match 3
Ambit 52 va s853 exactement Maxime et
que ça dure 7 heures ça ce serait
vraiment le scénario de rêve
finale d'anthologie dans ce tournoi
c'est l'équivalent d'un Grand Chelem
master
dans l'année plus un méga mega Grand
Chelem de fin de saison c'est
l'équivalent d'un Australian Open qu'on
gros de gagner ce tournoi si on veut
comparer au tennis Fab donc c'est comme
ça l'Australian et en avril il aura un
deuxième tour il sera l'équivalent un
peu d'un Roland Garros et donc il y en
aura aussi cette année avec un méga
master
donc là voilà pour vraiment resituer
l'enjeu Fab
mais c'est des grands Chelem tu vois
enfin l'Australienne c'est un grand
chelem créer ça pourrait être un nouveau
Grand Chelem en Chine un autre existant
un autre Chili c'est ça que des grands
endroits là et ouais en Finlande enfin
etc ce serait voilà c'est un renouveau
c'est autre chose c'est un grand chelem
ça qu'il faut comprendre donc forcément
les deux joueurs ont très envie de de
l'accrocher à leur palmarès
le premier premier Grand Chelem de la de
cette saison
entre les deux hommes mais en même temps
encore le
weekend
mais
quasiment plus de Grand Chelem peut-être
que Djokovic puisqu'il avait déjà joué
c'est la quatrième saison je crois des
champions de la troisième mais il en est
déjà accroché beaucoup à son palmarès
l'ogre norvégien il est en train de
mettre Djoko dans le rétro
c'est en fait tu te qualifie avec les
points que tu marches un peu comme le
master de tennis de tennis et tu finis
par te qualifier
et donc fin décembre ça rejoue à fond
avec deux tournois là qualificatif pour
les play-offs
et des joueurs qui seront déjà qualifiés
pour la grande finale pour une giga méga
finale de fin d'année
c'est comme l'équivalent d'un
paris-roubet d'un Milan 100 Mo
classique des Flandres mais pas à Paris
Roubaix en Hongrie quoi
ça pourrait être un peu
avec des pavés un peu voilà
magnifique
et la finale à mon avis ce serait
l'équivalent d'un tour de France ou
d'une Vuelta en fin d'année le grand
tournoi avec un tour de France à mon
avis
très beau comme un beau tour de France
en décembre
dans la montagne il faut que tu mettes
des skis sur ton vélo pour les descentes
ça c'est bien c'est format court avec un
grand intérêt de la part des meilleurs
joueurs du monde et ouais tu as tout
tous les meilleurs qui participent
et les deux meilleures qui sont toujours
en rendez-vous en finale
mais je pense que naive va la gagner
celle là
Magnus j'ai déjà vu faire une partie de
merde dans un truc comme ça
j'ai trouvé ratique pour
il peut pas bien poser son jeu
positionnel il a pas assez de temps
c'est un peu des coups d'attente là non
il attend pas vraiment tu bouges ton
cavalier tu fais x 41 c'est ouais c'est
pas du tout un coup d'attente c'est un
coup il get il peut aussi vouloir du
cavaler A4 pour rentrer le fou ou du X4
tout court il y a eu des cinq il y a de
partout
je suis pas du tout dans l'écran je sais
pas il faut me dire ça dans le chat
mais oui c'est pas le même pays ça
le deuxième ou pas
moins spécialiste d'Internet Maxime
on dit ça a commencé mais on va pas la
partie
j'ai l'impression qu'en fait on doit pas
la caméra qu'on va pas la partie
veut prendre de l'espace il veut créer
des brèches à l'endroit
bon j'ai tendance à jouer à 6 quand on
vient m'embêter comme ça mais peut-être
accepter se faire G6 mais ça m'embête
toujours moi
j'aime pas ça me chiffonne dans les
finales de taper H7 enfin c'est chiant
quoi
donc
on va voir ce qu'il fait il est encore
10 minutes il a le temps il a largement
le temps
voilà il a pas fait acheter
donc il provoque les changes il va
prendre la dame voilà pour échanger les
dames et il arrive vite sur B2
d'ailleurs éventuellement Magnus c'est
pas obligé d'échanger enfin peut-être il
serait même bien sûr de ne pas échanger
les dames
pour pas tous les risques B2 et puis se
dire ouais bon j'ai joué pour peut-être
attaquer le roi c'est cool que je garde
les dames donc dame 4 par exemple
c'est débile et juste défendre la dame
par tours ça bizarre aussi
tu regardes les dames et tu parles
là-bas avec des dames G4 des trucs
peut-être aussi le défendre avec des
deux
je comprends pas trop les temps IRL
perdent l'importance on aura quand même
bah il y a moins d'argent c'est moins
des grands Chelem quoi c'est
c'est juste des Chelem voilà
d'ailleurs de tennis j'imagine qu'il y a
une plus grande récompense de prix pour
les grands Chelem que dans les
ATP mine ou 500 on va prier 250
est-ce que ça a vraiment joué les games
ça va égaliser pour jouer l'armée donc
bah écoute là ça a l'air de jouer hein
ça joue en fait souvent il joue de toute
façon et c'est la dernière qui carot
mais à la poubelle avec les Blancs pour
l'armée
maxime a dit qu'il jouera en cliqueur
éclairer le prochain en avril
qui tombera juste avant le match
championnat du monde
comment je fais pour voir mon ello
théorie que je vais dans bilan de partie
JP 62
c'est une nouvelle options pourcentage
et maintenant
qui dit bon ça a pas l'air dit qu'il
fallait garder les dames mais je sais
pas moi ça me semblait le coup plus
plus de principes on va dire voilà dans
la position après avoir
mais évidemment après faut regarder de
plus près après qu'il y a 5 qui se passe
d'ailleurs bon il a fait tourner donc
après évidemment
il le provoque pas donc le cahier reste
en B6 il est pas un 4 pour les taper B2
pourrait peut-être prendre pour quand
même faire cavaler à 4 après
éventuellement
donc la tour
donc peut-être pour B1 voilà évite
l'attaque et redescend B2 donc comme ça
si ensuite un échange d'âme peut-être au
moins la tour sera mieux placé pour déjà
des défendre le pion
moi je mise vraiment surnaka dans cette
partie tout de suite
en plus je sais pas pourquoi je sens
qu'il va y avoir de match là
je sens vraiment victoire de Naka s'il y
avait du bookmaker il y en a pas mais je
serai prêt à miser très très gros sur
victoire de Naka dans le premier match
je pense que c'est très en forme très
affûté de ouf
il fait trop l'effort dans le premier il
pourrait perdre le second parce qu'il
aurait fait trop les phares et
payer peut-être ensuite son être à court
de souffle
[Musique]
mais j'imagine
c'est c'est vraiment le scénario de
match que j'attends après on verra si
j'ai raison ou tort je peux avoir tort
Magnus qui déconne le roi donc voilà
c'est pas un souci de se dire ok étant
donné de toute façon il y a déjà poussé
le pion h donc il comptait probablement
par OK plutôt activer la tour via
H4 VH3 on verra
et
il a fait ses cinq ok bien ici de
taquiner ce centre blanc
pourrait lui coûter un pion mais
peut-être qu'il se dit qu'elle est
condensations qu'aupir et recrae passera
avec la deuxième tour après là-bas donc
la première G6
voilà quand même ça peut devenir
dangereux là je suis d'accord avec toi
mais j'aime pas laisser je suis mais
c'est peut-être pas si grave c'est juste
un ressenti qui me plaît pas
c'est un bo combien c'est un bo4 il y a
quatre parties
il y en aura une cinquième
[Musique]
je donnerai pas davantage alors Dink qui
donne plus simple mais je suis pas du
tout d'accord en fait
je suis pas d'accord avec ça je suis pas
d'accord avec ce plus simple
je sais pas bah il doit juste être
content de gagner un pion et te dire que
voilà lui il est content quoi mais
humainement et en pratique ça a pas
l'air ça me semble simple quoi c'est
hyper compliqué
franchement tout peut t'arriver il y en
a pas non
demander si Naka gagne la première tu
penses qu'il fait la nul dans la
deuxième tempo
oh il est très pragmatique un carreau
donc bon on verra
carvana encore encore concentré donc ils
ont il a dû perdre la première il a dû
gagner la première finale et il doit
être dans la deuxième finale fait il
devait être en looser quoi
la situation du carreau aujourd'hui quoi
en fait ouais
je pense qu'il était en looser
et qui passe en winner quoi
plus de 51 mois je mets pas plus de 50
ans là non non après peut-être avec
voilà mais vu comme ça je sais pas trop
comment évaluer quoi
enfin bon je vois que ça devrait gagner
un pion pour les blancs mais je me dis
ok bon tu vas faire tirage ramener la
Tour Eiffel 8 et je sais pas mais bon
souple m'agace quoi je vois des
problèmes à long terme je vois que si on
rock évidemment on peut avoir des soucis
tu vois je suis en train de me dire que
au lieu d'avoir la double finale ils
auraient pu aussi faire un truc sympa
c'est qu'en cas de match nul celui qui
avait gagné a gagné le truc quoi s'ils
veulent donner un avantage
ah oui
voilà c'était une autre manière de
procéder bien sûr et toi
pour venir voilà utiliser cette tour sur
la colonnage qui a une action
horizontale
et qui vient d'attaquer le pion C4
pas aux yeux le plus de 5 hein non mais
pour les blancs
C4 prise C4 dam prend
je sais pas et c'est compliqué je vais
peut-être faire
5 enfin j'en sais rien moi non mais
c'est pas fini
[Musique]
mais bon
après s'il perd un cas ici
c'est pas ce serait dommage quand même
oui oui on raterait deuxième match les 8
parties etc mais après si Magnus
s'impose vite après aussi gagner au
blanc il a pas il est pas obligé de
perdre non pas obligé jamais bon là il
va il va gagner tu vas voir
allez il nous faut le Naka
je pense qu'il nous faut un petit mur un
petit mur de barbelé ou un truc là pour
Naka ça serait tellement tellement
dommage que les pilotes soient si rapide
aujourd'hui
on veut le deuxième match qui compte
pour tout
enfin qui est en train de réfléchir qui
calcule qui fait un peu comme ça il lève
les yeux et ce qui cherche le plafond
Fab
là ils dansent pas trop
c'est plus ou moins simple attention
oiseau de mauvaise augure
bird of mauvaise badogue
ouais non mais attends
oui il fallait me
c'est ton verdict après bon oui de 5 ans
je trouve
mais que les blancs soient mieux
en tout cas rien qui pioche un peu trop
d'un cas en Muret
qui boit de l'eau mais on le voit pas la
caméra
dans le noir
je sais pas
mais bon ça joue on va sur tout ça
bref
voilà la position alors qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé
en fait
donc Magnus a gagné son pion comme prévu
diawami les tours sur les colonnes BC
comme prévu et
on verra il va faire quoi encore te
faire qui est des 5 Damas 2 enfin ça va
quoi pour ikaro non non mais ça c'est
pas fini on est d'accord bon après tu as
toujours ton roi un peu pourri quoi
ouais mais en dessin qui va te tenir la
case F6 un jour je fais qu'il y a eu
cette F1 je bondis je jaillit partout je
vais à un moment donné je vais jaillir
et je vais
tu fais des flèches partout
je pense tu veux faire un dôme
Saint-Jacques de me prendre HS
[Musique]
non mais
suis un peu mais quand même le pur H6
est plus protégé à un moment donné je te
fais un janu sans C1 et je vais le
prendre enfin
je te fixe de partout et je suis très
très bien avec les Noirs en fait
à deux doigts
j'ai peur de 3,5 de tout reprend des
cinq et aussi
[Musique]
je sais pas quoi vous dire les gars
[Rires]
qui est en train de ouais il nous montre
la voie à suivre
cette année on doit essayer de
mais là ça devient dur il a plus de
temps d'un cas à assez dur si par la
première psychologiquement j'ai peur
direct non c'est pas magazon
c'est 4 parties pourquoi j'écris un mail
à écrire un magasin ça a pas changé
ils me font peur en fait j'écris final
ils me font hyper peur dans le chat
en fait
c'est horrible en fait on comprend rien
on est là mais
nous on comprend rien ça c'est sûr mais
on clique
à 5 OK
je pense qu'il va défendre quand
virgule
pour faire d'un F3 et de M6
mais bon
[Rires]
en tout cas il est pas bien
la part dedans c'est pas qu'il est pas
de danse c'est juste qu'il y a une
position catastrophique et que
il était en train de perdre le match
mais bon après c'est pas très grave
après c'est quand même c'est un final de
Grand Chelem quoi d'autre on aura
d'autres ouais
il y en a quand même gagné beaucoup déjà
d'un cas des grands je t'aime
c'est pas un Grand Chelem de plus ou
moins qui va le
qui va le mettre à mal
mais je sens que ça a l'air fort
comme tu disais le roi est faible
ouais
pour bloquer les deux pions blancs et
espérer faire dame C4 échanger mettre un
cahier en C4 et c'est de tenir cette
finale
mais le truc c'est que tu es pas à
l'abri de tout mais en fait on en reste
faible sur les maths du couloir
tâche 7 il faut surveiller pour toutes
les trucs dans les finales donc je veux
dire malgré tout
sorti de l'Homère quoi
même si plus
pourquoi pas
voilà donc le scénario dont on parlait
un truc genre
prise trop d'essai qui prend B2 qui
valide ici qui est 4 peut-être tu
reprends F7 il prend à 3 donc j'essa 38
quoi
c'est bien joué
ce qu'il y a une idée cachée sur tour
d'essai tu fais tour des 4
il y a quoi comme idée
rien plus ou moins parce qu'on n'a pas
encore qualifié cinq vues 5 mais bon
il est plus ou moins bloqué avec le noir
quoi
manger avec ta tour sinon yamahat et tu
peux pas te barrer avec le roi et j'ai 5
qui arrive donc tu es tu es dans le
cadeau
il a pris bon j'imagine que j'ai 5
ou peut-être un coup de corset 7 pour
pas être quand même réussi à faire
c'est étonnant mais on n'arrive pas à
terminer
F4 et C4 G4 qui prend à 3 F5
tu prends tout un F5 E6 tu vois
ça suffit pas je crois que c'est le truc
pour le contrôle alors tu fais F4 ou 3
F4 et après tu repars en dessert et au
moins tu as plus de problème avec le
pion au 5e
[Musique]
on bouffe et on essaie de te présenter
c'est pas fait encore quand même
on peut montrer très vite ton idée
Bondy ouais c'est ça huit
pour ces trois rois des deux il va
sûrement partir pour ses 7 j'imagine
non
encore
je sais pas trop ce qu'on a quoi
mon 3D de torset 7 sans me défendre mais
tomber 4 maintenant
un peu dans le même truc que tout à
l'heure
qui tient pour le moment
issue mais bon encore perdu mais
4 il va tenter de défendre comme ça
il s'est réussi à repasser via E5 sur
échec des 7 F8 tu vois pour essayer de
de serrer
qui arrive pas à le finir
c'est sûr que c'est tour B4 le coup
cavalier s'éclater chaque c'est forcé
mais attention
ce qui arrive de faire tourner fuite
peut-être qui est G4 qui prend H6
et après revenir j'ai quatre directs
mais sur quoi alors dit donne F3 qui
échange tout et garde le pion passé
tu aurais pu F3 ça fait mal
ça ferme non
tomber 8 c'est un aveu de faiblesse hein
comme ça il pourra bouger son cavalier
le pion sera plus en prise il va revenir
en G5 il va venir terminer le travail
bon ça se finit
trop loin
toutes ces pièces sont mal placées
maintenant
3 ici a l'air de faire tellement mal
et
qui va repartir vers F4
et c'est abandon 1-0 pour Magnus qui a
fait très très très très très très très
mal à
aikaro dans cette partie et qui prend le
premier point c'est la crise pour Ikao
mener un zéro mener un 7 à 0 en quelque
sorte il est mené de toutes parts
et on peut dire qu'il est pas bien ah il
est un peu comme Parme
il est pas bien
et il va falloir rapidement se ressaisir
un côté américain sinon la finale
pourrait
vite tourner
cours
Mathieu qui est pas bien qui a pris 10
minutes il demande pourquoi tu as parlé
de Saint-Étienne le pauvre mais bon
c'était normal non
[Rires]
[Musique]
moi je reste quand même sur mon opinion
que qui va remonter Hikaru je suis pas
sûr
c'était pas une grande partie
et déjà hier tu vois c'était pas un
grand niveau de jeu donc
c'est vrai qu'il est assez mal joué hier
aussi
je sais pas trop
tu as pas de certitude non
et en Ligue 2
j'imagine
la première ronde donc bon
je suis très heureux de la Ligue 2
on sera là en Ligue 2 bon on regarde les
dommage que le vainqueur de la Ligue 2
joue pas après le vainqueur de la Ligue
1 pourquoi pas pour une sorte de super
final
de la division 2 en fait
sur sur un match en deux parties quand
même de ça c'est en Ligue 1 en Ligue 2
donc bon
[Musique]
c'est pas forcément plus fort quand tu
es en Ligue 1 en vrai non
ça se joue sur un coup de dés
c'est dommage qu'il y ait pas des
promotions cela le vainqueur avec deux
il m'arrêterait de jouer la Ligue 1 la
prochaine fois pourquoi il a gagné Ligue
en fait c'est génial au foot c'était
pareil
le PSG ils ont raté leur mode au mois de
juillet
j'aime bien ce truc de division au
contraire ça rajoute du piment c'est pas
dans quelle division tu vas être des
mecs très forts qui étaient en division
3 qui était plus fort que des mecs étant
en division quoi tu es dans une division
ça joue sur deux parties donc
une caméra
attends j'ai deux pubs il est repartir
[Musique]
plusieurs fois le saut qui est très haut
qui
c'est assez beau non
[Rires]
[Musique]
du coup ça a gagné ça a perdu il s'est
passé quoi la première ronde
après on sait pas il y a une autre ça
fera une Armageddon de
qui était vraiment heureux
ça repart alors attends
au mur il revient hop il roule sur la
alors
on imagine qu'il triche pas
de miséraux
donc il veut nous rejoindre en première
Magnus qui change par rapport à l'autre
jour où il avait joué avec C5 et donc
ikiro le laisse jouer E5 finalement
l'idée des Noirs ici de prendre le
centre et ça fait une sorte de pire
qu'un verset la honte que tu joues avec
des trous et que j'ai 3 mais bon
ce serait beau quand même de faire
semblant que tu arrives pas aimer ta
caméra tricher une deux parties après
tarif
une idée pour Maxime
2 et 0 bonsoir
[Rires]
un petit peu les amis
bon je suis
ah oui non mais en fait sont décalés par
rapport à nous
OK
ça va mais je pense qu'il peut juste
faire des quatre
même des Français
mais des quatre en général c'est pas
idiot
pour pour les blancs ça non non bon une
autre idée pour les Noirs
c'est comme un dragon j'ai trop inversé
il y a pas mal de manières de jouer mais
en fait ça va enfin c'est jouable pour
les blancs
il veut pas les chercher Magnus sur le
terrain théorique il veut juste jouer
une partie et voilà donc pourquoi pas ça
va jouer
il a pas l'air fringants et Caro
aujourd'hui
donc Magnus a pris ok
bien sûr
et d'ailleurs c'est une option
stratégiquement intéressante qui
employait pour emmurer une fougère
ça a l'air d'aller pour les noirs
c'est bien de voir d'autres ouvertures
fait des berlinoises il a raison ça
change un peu
est-ce que tu penses qu'une bonne
qualité d'air
j'espère pour eux
est-ce qu'on peut aller faire un tour
sur la qualité d'air de ranch
les Dr Fab côté Daniel range on peut
laisser sa qualité d'air voir si ça
évolue non mais en fait je dois dire que
sûrement peut-être un petit problème
d'air depuis un jour ou deux quoi
mais ils ont pas une tempête de froid
il y a un truc qui le fait rire
peut-être quelqu'un qui lui a écrit un
SMS
mais
je veux dire ouais non je sais pas une
sorte de tornade polaire ou je ne sais
quoi et
peut-être qu'il a un arrêt chez Vidy
alors comment
tu peux pas mais c'est pour ça qu'il est
pas en première division
[Musique]
beaucoup
il s'arrêtait à quel moment guérielle
en fait
par l'humidité 50% de l'unité dans sa
mais c'est rench en fait tant mais
Rennes qui va il va crever en fait 23%
des vidéos c'est très sec
c'est qui le dernier là
le congame
il a pas le chauffage le
frérotone je sais pas en fait cette
rapporte absolument pas de prix il était
à perdre depuis 10 ans avec ce site
là le chauffage marche pas il essaye de
c'est ça c'est comme les serveurs
il doit pas être bien Rennes mais je
pense qu'on peut laisser l'air de Rennes
je crois si ça peut évoluer c'est on le
voit baisser de l'unité 23 22,9 17
degrés et tu vois c'est la pollution
augmentée c'est mais ça bouge pas trop
en fait de son côté
il est très stable il est très très
stable
j'ai un record de 29 à 29 degrés chez
moi très compliqué ah bah tu ne veux pas
te dire maximum dans le rouge quoi
mais elle doit pas être bien en fait il
a pas su brancher quoi
tu penses qu'il y a pas su branché
peut-être
[Musique]
peut-être qu'il a branché mais qu'on a
on n'a pas le bon le bon truc quoi
non mais il est pas bien en fait
il doit écouter quelqu'un qui lui parle
ou il y a un truc comme ça sur moi quand
ça fait de la merde je pense
probablement parce que tu peux pas être
mort de rire comme ça pendant si
longtemps
donc F3 pour essayer de redonner vie un
peu à ses pièces
notamment fougères
à cause de ces trucs
mais bon
une grande partie
pour les noirs
[Musique]
un petit peu la pression donc ça se
passe pour l'instant très très bien pour
pour Magnus et William
c'est tendu
si c'est dur
un truc qui le ramène dedans et puis on
sait jamais mais bon
en tout cas c'est pas en jouant comme ça
qui va de Magnus à mal ouais
il m'a pas l'air d'être prêt
il m'a pas l'air d'être prêt au combat
c'est comme ça le Fab
et nous on a pas de bottes j'espère que
vous l'entendez pas mais on se prend de
la perceuse depuis tout à l'heure c'est
un peu complexe si vous n'entendez
parfois arrêter de parler c'est que bon
qui fait de la perceuse
je crois que c'est un appartement juste
en dessous mais c'est légal en fait de
faire de la perceuse toute la journée
t'emmerder enfin légal Alpha
Omega
non mais je sais pas enfin tu dois
prévenir au moins ou je sais pas mais je
pense tu as le droit de faire un peu de
perceuse mais là
personne et il n'arrête pas quoi donc au
bout d'un moment c'est le prix de la
perceuse plus mélodieux que l'autre truc
avant qui était super strident
donc B3 je veux pas les carreaux qui
consolide sa structure pion qui peut
développer le foot gaz noire peut-être
en B2 lutter un peu la grande diagonale
voilà et puis ça libère le Calais à
trois aussi qui était jusque là la
défense du pion C4 qui maintenant va
peut-être pouvoir venir en C2 pour
contrôler un peu les cases rebondir on
ne sais où mais ce sera toujours mieux
que 1 à 3
place le roi pas besoin de roquet pour
la finale le ranch sera plus actif
de jouer
peut-être tout ressemble tout à 8 autour
des 8 je sais pas
le voisin qui installe peut-être le
boîtier arcing et oui en fait c'est ça
il a vu il doit se dire oui bon
on avait peut-être pas la qualité de son
air quoi donc ici c'est pas
il a
gagné 0,1%
bravo
petite réaction qui va dans le bon sens
on espère pour lui
je pense qu'il va la perdre ça en fait
hyper chiante à jouer au blanc
pas trop trop bien
puis surtout tu fais rien
de blanc bon ça c'est dur dans la tête
aussi
clairement c'est le dernier qui est le
meilleur de mon organisé
c'est pas le capitaine non non
espèce
déjà le mec qui a discuté récemment
d'Aurélien Barrow et c'est quoi sur le
chat quoi
[Rires]
c'est des codes en fait c'est c'est
clairement un code avec un autre gars
mais c'est pas lui qui s'était fait
faire un bébé dans le dos de voir 24 86
possible hein
oui ça me bute quoi
avec les Blancs
un peu tout seul mais ça va ça va pas
être si dur à défendre
l'anastrophysie
on connaît quoi mais pas le physicien
quoi voilà c'est de la physique aussi
après notre
très bonne conférence il y avait un peu
les pendules à l'heure si on met les
pendules à l'heure j'ai deux trois
monstres à régler à la maison
tu vois au bout d'un moment oui bon
c'est peut-être lui qui fait les
pendules pour l'Armageddon là quand il
baisse le temps
ah c'est trop
c'est trop
me surprendra toujours
quand même
et tu sais oui
un peu de parties soporifique
moi aussi
c'est pas pour le moment c'est pas un
match très très emballant honnêtement
le premier édition il y a 2 jours était
plus
ambalante là on a moins de mais bon
c'est vrai que à force de enfin je sais
pas c'est comme si tu avais
Roland-Garros giocona dal vendredi et
puis dimanche puis dimanche c'est Rojo
Canada peut-être ça ferait aussi la même
impression possible
peut-être un peu de ça parce que
normalement dans les dans les tournois
espoirs en fait ils font le double
élimination parce qu'ils ont des formats
ça joue très court
donc c'est comme si c'est un truc là en
cas de Blitz
c'est tu dirais bon on fait le looser
bracket pour que les mecs reviennent
mais c'est vrai que là c'est 4 parties
quand même longueur du coup peut-être
c'est pour ça que ça fait cet effet on
copier les jeux vidéo mais pas jusqu'au
bout et donc c'est pour ça qu'on a
peut-être un peu cet effet après tu me
diras League of Legends tu as aussi le
double élimination mais tu as une phase
de poules assez longue et après tu as
des playoffs
un truc de barrage de machin où tu te
bats ou tu te retrouves en looser
bracket fait tu as des mecs qui sont
directement vous arbre à quatre il
rentre dans les playoffs mais ils sont
en loser bracket
du coup tu penses le format mieux
calibré peut-être non je sais pas non
non j'en sais rien en fait tu as
l'équivalent de ouais à la fin c'est
peut-être comme c'est deux divisions et
simplement
de talent
j'ai une bonne nouvelle ils sont arrêtés
de percer
c'est un bo4 au début et si les gagner
Paris caru il y a un deuxième bo2
mais voilà je pense à faire
mon avis de base que Caro va gagner ce
match allez c'était mon avis de mal de
base très beau si vous êtes une belle
remontada je pense qu'il va gagner qu'on
aura droit
à la grande finale et d'ailleurs si
c'est le cas on fera deux vidéos
ok pour faire plus d'argent
après demain
un petit chat
aussi Angers
parce qu'ils ont Bundesliga
trois parties
alors moi j'ai vite
pour prendre des quatre tu reprends les
quatre frères c'est peut-être qui est G4
son idée
probablement
de force
[Musique]
mais moi j'adore trolls
je connaissais je t'emmerde
on a beaucoup vu sur les réseaux sociaux
il y a peut-être deux trois ans de ça
attends
parler d'écologie aussi dans un certain
moment
mais c'est conférences je crois qu'elles
sont sur un autre sujet
il était assez présent dans les médias
il y a genre peut-être deux ans
non mais c'est très tranquille pour
Magnus
problème
à la prochaine
de jouer avec les parents
position où il peut à peu près c'est
sans trop de risque comme l'autre jambe
s'il a un peu le genre de position qu'il
avait l'autre fois où il peut presser
sans trop de risques
autant qu'il fasse
c'est la même tête plus fort sans
qu'elle sait si
je suis un peu
c'est le nouveau messie de l'écologie
ouais ben vu la forme de Messi
actuellement giga officiel 55 je suis
pas sûr qu'il soit bien
perdu à Marseille là début de semaine
jusqu'à
forcément tendu et j'ai pas remarqué le
nom en fait
mais là comme ça non ça me dit rien je
peux pas faire semblant de dire oui je
connais enfin
par rapport au fou
voilà alors je sais pas
en fait donc dur de se dire
et puis voilà
ça non il y a aucun problème oui mais
aucun problème pour les blondes non plus
enfin ce serait plus les blancs qui
pourraient être sous problème avec cause
du rapport matériel mais je crois que ça
va complètement non
après j'ai tendance de bien aimer le fou
fantastique
mais naturellement j'aurais préféré
jouer avec les Blancs
c'est un joli coup
mais surtout que j'adore la ligne de
l'ordi mais c'est hyper dur
ça c'est quand même chiant
peut-être pas perdant méchant ils n'ont
pas perdant mais
sur F4 G4 c'est 4 je pense là j'ai 5 et
tu te fais complètement fixer
il peut trouver F4 mais F4 reprend des
trois c'est pas simple trouvable mais
pas simple
après un truc bon même s'il fait pas il
faut autre chose c'est pas grave non
plus et après deux trente
tu peux te prendre un une fourchette
quand un cheval il a trouvé
bien bien joué
costaud quand même F4 pas facile de
l'avoir
prendre des trois fois F5 faut quand
même être très aiguisé votre affuteur il
faut être très très affûté
de toute façon il doit prendre
donc faut essayer de tenir l'autre
ouais c'est difficile là pour les Caro
bah si personne là objectivement
il faut rester en vie
mais il a l'air de suer là
il suffit
complètement
c'est dur c'est dur pour le joueur
américain
après revenir deux jours après une
défaite quant à suer dans le loser et
tout ça doit pas être simple je pense à
plus de chance si tu es chaud et que tu
avais pas joué de match avant
objectivement il faut prendre F4 et la
défendre
c'est juste pénible
sur blanc machin mais bien sur la 2e le
roi noir qui va s'activer
mais [__] mal autant comme ça c'est
pas c'est pas une bonne chose après ils
peuvent t'en prendre des trois tempes il
aurait pu aussi faire un H3 qui était
aussi une option du coup tu auras ça tu
reviens F5 il prend des trois mais c'est
une puce de pièces plus de pion quoi
il doit regarder peut-être un coup comme
cavalier 5 aussi est-ce que c'est
faisable
c'est pas un bon troc ça je sais pas si
tu dois prendre quand même jouer l'autre
finale après tu peux regarder
je sais pas mais bon
C4 et qu'en prenant ces 5 il active sa
tour je crois que c'est très bien joué
P4 mais bon il en pouvait tous ces pions
quoi
ouais mais il bloque un peu l'activité
adverse quand même
je crois que c'est bien joué
un pion et envoyer l'autre après
le coup que je regarderai mais il y a de
retour B6 pour penser 5 tu reprends G6
ou qui a valu 5 intermédiaires pour
garder le pied
la petite nulle peut-être
en G3
pour pouvoir monter après bien vu Fab
ça va probablement faire nul
je pense que ma news vu la situation du
match et voilà alors après bon si je
sens pas en danger il peut peut-être
jouer un je sais pas quoi un coup droit
c'est à 5
c'est pas si net autant faire nul c'est
pas grave
ça va bah c'est pas si net
Marie la joue
pour 5
cavaliers à 4
tu vois enfin ça peut ne pas
c'est bien joué qui a des quatre il veut
tomber 6 et même un petit mur au roi
mais il y a une couillasse il y a un
truc genre tu reprends un je crois à
tourber 6-3 bouge c'est 6 puis on prend
tout reprendre et c'est ce que c'était
pris Carlson contre
j'avais pas oui mais tu paieras 6 ouais
de toute façon il va faire ces six là
c'est sûr
en fait ce que tu vas voir c'est passé
quand même
ok c'est ça encore mieux pour cavaler ça
quoi c'est la même on a eu la même idée
de manière de manière différente mais
qui est ici c'est joli coup
rien qui est ici
à mon avis il aurait pu
être avec le reste ça marche mieux
maintenant ça marche plus ouais
bah maintenant il doit faire nul
je crois qu'il a un peu deg de pas la
cam j'ai vu ça il a fait une petite
grimace je pense qu'il était deg de pas
avoir tenter ici
ça devait pas gagner mais je pense
c'était plutôt les blancs qui
regardez juste pour voir où on fait une
petite pause aussi pour souffler je sais
pas alors les deux
cinq échec d'abord j'essaie qui est G3
c'est ça qui gagne
mais du coup qui est 6 je pense qu'il a
vu un postériori
en fait c'est plutôt dangereux parce que
le pion avec le fouet
on peut se faire une petite pause et
revenir dans 5 petites minutes à tout de
suite les amis à tout de suite
[Musique]
et voilà on est de retour avec cette
super vidéo d'intro qu'on aime bien Fab
et ça repart on a vraiment le timing
maintenant par contre le score il y a un
demi point de marque cadeau
de chaque côté et il y a eu quoi trop
pour pour Magnus et Hikaru qui réfléchit
d'entrer alors là la question c'est ce
que tu tentes quelque chose ou tu mises
tout sur la dernière
mais bon
normalement c'est quoi son
berlinoise et italienne
je sais pas ce qu'il veut jouer d'autres
en face mais il doit se demander si ça
joue la dro ou pas
c'est beau en fait
c'est 5 OK
c'est bon réfléchit quoi
qu'est-ce que je peux jouer contre ça
quoi
OK
de la de la pub
elle est belle la pub
en tout cas ça réfléchit dur
alors c'est premier coup fables combat
est intense
le coup quasi tout le temps
plus rare et je sais pas à quel point
mon bon mais
mais voilà donc voilà dessus plutôt
Torin côté blanc
et puis ces trois D4
on va voir c'est répertoires
compliqué pour les Noirs je vois pas
trop l'intérêt de jouer ça
je sais pas ouais tu fais ces trois de
toute façon il va te faire assis tu vas
partir en F1 il y aura priori il faut G4
tu fais d'ailleurs sur ces trois si tu
peux faire ces quatre intermédiaires il
y en a qui aiment bien qu'on soit B5
plus de casse pareil mais tu as provoqué
B5 après tu penses à faire à 4 on verra
enfin bon c'est une petite subtilité
possible mais en général tu fais tu fais
donc C3 ici de toute façon à 6 tu te
casses en F1 faut que j'ai 4 H3 et les
Noirs après deux choix soit ils prennent
un F3 soyez recul
de toute façon ça va arriver donc on va
on va laisser les coups venir à nous
les deux hommes en fait on l'air de se
poser des questions existentielles
[Musique]
qui peuvent partir ou quoi si tu veux
[__] un peu le bordel
je sens que ça peut être marrant comme
quoi
pourtant j'ai 8 G4
mais oui au moins il y a plus j'ai 4 je
pense
connaître enfin si moi je
en fait si toi tu connais un truc c'est
que tout le monde sait bah oui enfin
j'espère bien mais bon il connaissent
beaucoup plus loin ouais bon après les
carreaux
tu t'en vas
et j'ai 5 ans
ça fait un peu à la vie
je pense
ça va fixe une partie entre Adams et
Isham genre en 2004 ou il y a longtemps
longtemps
ouais
depuis toujours un S je crois ah oui je
crois un puis avec plusieurs gouttes
dedans et donc c'est pas mais ce genre
de pluie quoi
il y en a qu'un je crois que c'est
toujours au pluriel je crois un puits je
pense
on va nous confirmer ça dans une minute
trente Fab fuite Z
puis s'en fout
S
[Musique]
en fait disons je suis pas sûr à quel
point c'est
correct côté noir mais quand tu veux
jouer pour le gain bon bah tu cliques
hein
OK
ok alors dis donne Caroline D4
je sais pas chelou
cette partie Fab on attend de voir les
cliques pour le moment les joueurs sont
sur des territoires inconnus
mais je dois parler ils ont pas le clip
aussi
spontanément un peu de temps pour être
bien sûr des coûts
ça fait quoi
de toute façon on sait si Dame prend F3
tours G8
et on va voir après ouais c'est parti un
peu chaotique mais
[Musique]
qui doivent mieux correspondre au style
de après est-ce que vaut voilà c'est ça
le truc ouais
[Rires]
je sais que c'est intéressant comme à
l'époque il était Adams en plus il était
top maintenant
il les a pas je pense mais
peut-être 40 ouais
au moins 45
pas non plus si mais je pensais que
j'avais un peu moins de 50 ans
ça va quand même à 50 pigeons
en dessous de 2007
pour vieillir
un peu moins précis soit plus ennuyer
les parties longues qui dure
ah bon tu vas manquer de précision en
fait peut-être des coups de défense à la
con
ça fait chier mais oui mais je crois
qu'il a joué le week-end dernier ou
enfin ou pas d'ailleurs mais avec Baden
déjà
et ouais Adams c'était un très très beau
joueur quand on était jeune il a eu dû
être top 5 mondial je pense peut-être 3
d'ailleurs
qui joue bien tu comprends ce qu'il fait
c'est un style mais c'est très propre
mais c'est très difficile à répéter le
truc c'est qu'il faut de la précision
et lui là
ça me tenait de lui parler
[Rires]
je te parle plus connard
bah ouais mais
c'était des beaux jours d'antan
es
[Musique]
je sais pas
il voulait E5
un peu dégueu ça pique les yeux
j'ai pas en tête en fait
pas forcément le style pour bas de Gary
ce sont des Français ouais il essayait
en plus ces attaques anglaises dans les
nageurs
pas assez pêchu numéro 4
je comprends enfin je veux dire oui
ouvre le jeu logique
le meilleur jeu avec le style le plus
incompréhensible et confus
morosevitch qui était un truc un peu
particulier qui a été numéro 2
maintenant
c'est pas tout le temps d'ailleurs mais
c'est quand il veut
maintenant
tu as besoin d'être académique pour
savoir faire quand débute
n'importe quoi et bon on verra bien en
même temps en fait c'est devenu un super
joueur de finale avec le temps d'un
joueur hyper solide en fait
[Musique]
qui ont vraiment récemment en tout cas
réussi à avoir un style farfelu et
qui s'était fait marcher dessus par Vlad
en Coupe du monde
des cartes de finale j'imagine
contre
il était bien les deux fois
dans le débat ouais non dépôt c'est
assez classique comme s'il en fait
il a fait des efforts récemment en plus
je veux dire avant ça restait pas
n'importe quoi non plus c'était une âge
d'or française au début il aime bien il
aime bien envoyer il aime bien
l'initiative tout ça mais là en fait tu
vois il s'est mis à faire des pétroles
agrandir son répertoire etc tu vois
c'est on comprend ce qu'il fait quoi
[Musique]
avec les blancs des trucs tu sais plus
du Moyen-Âge là
ça l'embêtait pas d'essayer enfin etc
quoi c'est le contre Gambie Albin aussi
sur des cannes
au début après des fois reste la solides
des fois tu sortais une idée plus enfin
tu savais jamais où il allait aller il
est toujours une idée il est toujours
fait un truc bizarre
vraiment l'air de rien
la stratégie
de force un peu
c'était top 2 mais Maxime aussi je
mettrai pas dans les joueurs qui ont des
styles incompréhensible il est très
dynamique etc mais quand on pense qu'il
fait ça veut pas dire qu'on saurait
faire ça c'est dur à faire ce qu'il fait
mais il va pas t'envoyer des ouvertures
bizarres à tout va il va pas
ça il me roserichent comme tu le disais
il pouvait te cliquer un peu n'importe
quoi n'importe quand
cette possibilité de trouver des
attaques sur le roi quand elle a
l'impression qu'il y avait rien
j'ai pas en tête tu dis bon il y a rien
et quatre coups après il y a toutes les
pièces sur le bras je sais pas trop
pourquoi ou comment
surtout à l'époque maintenant on est
plus l'habitude
ça peut plus arriver puis mon Moro est
aussi passé par là mais à l'époque il
faisait des choses un peu
pas comme pas comme tout le monde quoi
il y avait eu un très gros rhini
je pense partir de 2010 par là déjà
c'était fini quoi
c'était un très beau joueur mais oui qui
devait bien convenir à vlades du coup
toi tu veux
qui avait des bons résultats contre lui
mais bon plus ça progresse plus on
avance dans les ouvertures plus ça sera
difficile d'avoir ces styles là de toute
façon dans tous les cas
puisque les ouvertures vont de plus en
plus loin les prépasteurs vont de plus
en plus loin c'est de plus en plus
précis et ça laisse de moins en moins de
place à la créativité pure et dure
existe encore mais c'est alpha zéro
est-ce que comme créatif
c'est une créativité différente c'est
très beau aussi hein
toi tu guides un peu ou tu cliques pour
aller voir ton côté mais bon
Anthony Maëlle serait mais bon
c'est pas le même
il a pas trop de perspective
[Musique]
partir mais après
il a pas voulu tout jouer sur une partie
il a voulu commencer à mettre la
pression avec les Noirs mais c'est
où ils vont pourquoi pas en fait c'est
vrai que plus tu joues plus tu joues de
partie plus tu as de chance en fait
plutôt gagner une seule mais il est
enfin la règle de Murtas
[Musique]
qui te dit comment enfin ne risque pas
trop pour le gain
tant que tu es pas complètement obligé
tant que tu es pas obligé à 100%, tu
joues la position
c'est que quand tu es obligé que tu
commences à vraiment
tu es pas en ligne quoi
age et jouer normalement tu peux un peu
essayez vraiment mais tu prends pas de
risque inconsidéré pour rien tant que tu
es pas obligé en fait
voilà c'est un peu ce qu'il a fait qui
va s'en sortir mais il en a un peu trop
fait quoi
ça aurait été plus compréhensible à la
troisième avec les blancs de faire ça ou
tu dis bon j'ai les Noirs là
de toute façon je sais pas il fait des
trucs à contre-courant de ce qu'on
ferait tout le temps en fait quand il a
les blancs quand il y a un demi j'aide à
la poubelle
[Musique]
il fait au lit avec les noirs
ce que je veux dire c'est que si perd
pas ça me tendu
toute façon tu te donnes tu t'es pas
donné tellement de chance de gagner
malheureusement
ouais mais après tu peux espérer que ton
adversaire comme il est dans une
situation confortable
je vais je vais je vais prendre la ligne
tranquille mais après l'autre problème
du carreau c'est que tu peux te dire je
peux toute façon je peux abuser avec les
Blancs parce que même si je perds c'est
pas il revient au score
et il fera nul
pour faire un Armageddon il y a un truc
je comprends absolument pas car on a
c'est que la troisième cawana ils sont
encore assis c'est peut-être un deuxième
Satan 4 quoi
pour la finale peut-être une mauvaise
information c'est peut-être deux fois 4
pour avoir 10 parties j'espère si on
pouvait me confirmer côté de chasse
comme parce que c'est vrai que du coup
ça veut dire que ouais
ça pourrait être beau
en tout cas on est parti bizarre de la
part du carreau il tente ce qu'il peut
mais ouais il a pas été très
tôt bon et après il arrive à comme d'hab
hein
de de le battre dans cette position mais
je suis pas très inquiet pour Magnus
après il y a le temps quand même ça
commence à être 5-40 contre 3 10
en vrai de vrai
[Musique]
du tout mais bon tu vois du coup
ça stratégie qui est un peu à l'envers
de ce qu'on ferait elle trouve ça
justification là-dedans si les mecs
essayent pas honte de te battre à la fin
pourquoi pas un peu risqué tiens il doit
il doit faire confiance à ses capacités
défenses à toi
et c'est un 7 en 4ème Val et oui pour la
finale et oui on a peut-être deux sept
en quatre
c'était en quatre non c'est en deux mais
en fait c'est la finale c'est la finale
de la finale tu peux avoir deux trucs en
casse ah mais ça ça va être
extraordinaire
il faut absolument qu'on commande juste
toutes les finales tout le temps en fait
ça va être magnifique
ah il faut absolument qu'il carugaille
les amis oh bah ouais bah là c'est la
rive de ouf
ah ouais non mais Fab siga il y en a
encore quatre parties derrière
ça ce serait beau
non mais c'est obligé qui car on gagne
en fait on a faim il a pas le droit de
nous enlever ça avec un ouf le porno
ah ouais c'est on se fait le vendredi
tranquille machin et tout
allez Koo allez le h faut gagner le HC
le S je sors le RS
glou glou à ce moment là aussi
[Musique]
wesh
pourquoi tu allumes la mèche
moi j'écoute pas les gens à ma clio sur
les jantes
comme ça certains moments
après dans un monde idéal la finale
serait cool
[Musique]
F6 je me disais dame G4 d6tchange d'un
coup je te fais agir tu peux plus
défendre F2
partout et je te défonce
allez Koo ah non si c'est bo4 derrière
en fait si c'est bo2 bon il perd c'est
pas si grave mais si c'est bo4 derrière
c'est grave en fait
on peut pas rater un tel truc en fait
franchement on peut pas rater le bo4 on
peut pas passer à côté quoi non on peut
pas Fab
iennes
merde surtout pas qu'il le fasse
ouais il le fait pas
il trouve tout les carreaux
je vais tellement le détester si il
gagne ce match non mais s'il gagne le
deuxième je m'en fous enfin genre bravo
à toi mais tu as pas le droit de vous
enlever ça en fait
je le vois pas gagner cette partie là
j'ai peur que la dernière il est du mal
quand même ça a gagné
il a pas envie de jouer un deuxième
match en quatre parties
je sais pas ça serait bien qu'il a envie
bien sûr que ce serait bo4 mais ouais
mais c'est trop en fait c'est bo4 c'est
trop important qui gagne en vrai
non mais c'est horrible si on rate ça le
remake je trouve ça exceptionnel en fait
parce que en fait tous les événements la
finale elle peut durer
potentiellement 6h30 ou 7h
il donne à fond
je vois pas pourquoi la division ça le
serait pas
mais bon je sais pas franchement je je
sais pas quoi vous dire
il y a énormément de règlement donc
c'est dur de tous d'avoir toute la mais
de base j'avais ça en tête moi c'était
deux fois bo4 la grande finale après on
m'a dit ouais mais non en fait la petite
finale c'est ça machin et tout du coup
c'est bo2 mais en fait non
c'est magnifique je pense c'est toujours
bo4 allez KO
ah le va nous chercher le deuxième match
vas-y mon saoulé avec leur débat sur le
chat je vais mettre des Théo et la
prochaine fois je mets des bandes
l'écologie ils sont à la fois c'est un
sujet important mais genre au bout d'un
moment là c'est pas l'endroit
pourquoi pas c'est mais c'est pas ici en
fait c'est il y a des endroits pour quoi
j'ai mis un Théo au hasard j'espère que
tout le monde
OK
[Musique]
déjà mieux que rien non mais moi
souvent ce que je fais tu vois un truc
qui sert à rien non plus mais bon moi je
crois que c'est utile et quand je
regarde un match à la télé que le ballon
il peut sortir je souffle sur les gants
mais oui pour je veux que le ballon il
dégage encore mer on s'y mettre je crois
pas qu'on puisse la gagner ça
quoi que
ça va être quand même
il peut tenter mais bon
allez
faut pas la perdre on l'attendent pas
il a l'air désespéré il est pas dedans
le frérot
allez
le H le double bo4
tombe tombe
allez la déco
range si un moment tu fais sauter tes
serveurs c'est maintenant le frérot
il est peut-être mieux il envoie les
punts
[Musique]
j'ai quasiment envie d'allumer le micro
de la lui donner toute la première ligne
de l'ordi eh regarde
pousse pousse oui let's go allez tourner
quoi trop
allez le H e h le H le H le H prend le
Punto prends le Punto
bref 5 tours des quatre allez pourquoi
il rigole [__] il rigole comme si
c'était nul [__] tu as la première
ligne de l'ordi frère bref 5 tu auras je
suis tombé 4 frérot
ouais 5 on va aller le ginkinama quoi
le roi F5 qui a écrivait dans son chat
ton écrit partout [__] j'ai envie
d'écrire là dans le chat de chaise com
tu vas la gagner frérot pas de panique
oui oui trouve tour des quatre ça gagne
tour des 4 oui tu l'as oui tu l'as va le
chercher va le chercher le double B au 4
[Rires]
allez let's go
oui c'est beau ce qu'il fait FCO on va
monter allez
donnez-moi h
h donnez-moi i I donnez-moi carte
donnez-moi ah ah donnez-moi r donnez-moi
u
ICO
allez
il est là le frérot
allez Pousse Pousse Pousse tranquille
pas de stress
tu as un Magnus dans chaque doigt
allez on panique pas il va réussir à le
faire t'inquiète t'inquiète
bah vraiment il va avancer de toute
façon il va être obligé de passer par
jouer
et là il tourne bien
pas facile torgée 8
j'espère pas si gagne pas je casse tout
oh [__]
quel jeu de merde il doit ça devrait
être facile à gagner en fait
je crois qu'ils sont brouillé non
à un moment donné
je vais devoir faire tourner
pas tout il passe
je sens que c'est complètement bloqué le
roi qu'il pouvait monter
il tente
bon au pire ouais
on va faire tout ça
ok ok bon c'est une tentative c'est pas
mal
du temps gagne du temps oui
ça peut être chiant là
je sais pas
je crois que tu peux juste pas en fait
il reste loin en fait avec sa tour
peut-être et après tu refais un tour des
six amis
c'était
j'aime bien
mange pas de pain
allez le Fab
la tête tu vas jusqu'en on va jusqu'au
bout du monde Fab il va y aller on va
jusqu'au bout du monde
on va lui pousser le pion dans la gueule
attends faut pas qu'il nous fasse des
échecs latéraux
ça devrait aller en progrès son progrès
son progresse on progresse
gagne la gagne la gagne là
bon
continue à avancer frérot
ça doit gagner ça c'est sûr F3 [__]
j'ai pas trop
comment
ça a l'air de gagner en fait
ce qui va monter le roi en F4 maintenant
bonjour
ok il veut refaire j'imagine
[Musique]
tu menaces tu menaces
j'ai bien peur que ça gagne plus les
gars mais bon
il y a plus de place pour le roi là
c'est la merde
tu es complètement bloqué
c'est pas possible
comment il a raté ça
échec à un bon moment
c'est dur en même temps
il peut pas il peut rien faire là
il est bloqué
il a aucune cachette pour le roi c'est
horrible
je suis dégoûté là
ah mais bon ok c'est dur enfin
je suis dégoûté au final c'est tellement
de
la précision que bon
une case ou quoi et puis voilà
tu peux rien faire en fait
incroyable
en fait
qu'est-ce qu'il a raté il a tellement
mal défendu Magnus aussi
bien défendu longtemps mais
il a laissé
après il a paniqué parce que tu auras
chaque soir la première et qu'il y avait
des trucs je sais pas moi mais
là il y a plus rien tout est bloqué toi
et passive au jeu
[Musique]
il a pas dû croire un truc dans ce truc
là
en fait
voilà
le roi est pire que tout à l'heure c'est
pas
c'est pas facile en fait
mais oui en fait le truc c'est qu'il
aurait pu faire ça et
c'est pas si simple et du coup en fait
juste pourquoi il a fait tomber un
Magnus est-ce que
tu vois parce qu'en fait il a fait
tomber un qui ok clairement l'ordi il
est pas content
OK
le truc le plus logique en fait de base
mais bon tout est bon
G2 en fait et le couper la bas et après
pousser
tu fais une sorte
bon encore une chance
mais bon c'était pas
c'est plus ou moins simple avec du temps
mais ça va gueule de facile en fait
c'est ça qui est terrible vraiment
je suis dégoûté
de 8 parties maximum on parlait de 10
parties
voilà le rêve du double
c'est déjà bien qu'ils pu mettre en
difficulté alors que pour quand même il
partait de loin
on a eu un vrai choc en fait
un vrai choc pour le double 4
[Musique]
je suis hyper dur
et revendre des changements c'est pas la
même position il sait pas faire mur une
fou
mais moi en fait du coup c'est pour ça
que j'aime bien jouer en fait pour
essayer de ne pas
je suis un peu ouais elle a laissé des
traces la dernière fable c'est reparti
trop vite je pense que les pauses sont
faites sont trop courtes sur ce tournoi
sur des postures
moi j'avais besoin de souffler
personnellement là
après ce moment
on était tellement mal on a même nous on
a pas passé de pub on a rien fait en
fait c'est dommage
non je vais peut-être le la vidéo de
scène comme tu mets ça un petit coup
[Musique]
et de ce passage en fait
du bien on a récupéré
on a les crier dans un
oreiller Fab
dommage
ça va être dur un psychologiquement
[Musique]
comme ça très
positionnel stratégique ou quoi
pas évident quoi
je pense que ça vient du carreau qui
doit pas avoir un super bonnet
de range
[Musique]
il a réparé ce qu'il fallait CO2
redescendu oui
ce qui est bien avec cet appareil c'est
qu'en plus voir
ma femme a toujours raison
surtout quand elle a tort
ça change pas en fait
ça c'est pas
enfin
il va te faire H3 il va essayer de
mettre le quai en des cinq en premier
c'est quand même un peu mieux pour les
blancs mais bon très léger quoi oui mais
bon ça existe quand même
on va y croire
[Rires]
les enchères
[Musique]
ça fait 4h30 de match là pour eux
après ils ont eu que trois parties dans
le premier match alors que nous c'est un
cas gagne et qui gagne l'Armageddon on
peut potentiellement avoir cinq parties
ça c'est vraiment magnifique
et l'enjeu de cette partie mais en gros
si Naka gagne il y a un Armageddon
et si Magnus perd pas c'est terminé
c'est pour ça que c'est vraiment hyper
important qui perdent
[Musique]
tellement proche tellement proche
c'est pas mal enfin je sens
pour éviter un peu l'expansion blanche
j'ai peur que ce soit un clap de fin
toujours triste de voir des tournois
comme ça s'arrêter
pour toujours pour l'éternité après tu
en plus il faut attendre jusqu'en avril
pour avoir le la deuxième édition
je pense pas ce serait l'armée
du coup leur partie elle est hyper Maine
s'il peut faire un troisième match en
cas de partie
mais peut-être pour la finale tu as un
mini match en deux et par Maguet en
direct après pour la finale de la finale
de la finale
c'est sûr qu'on suit ça moi je rends pas
l'antenne bon mais malheureusement on
sait pas si il va gagner ou pas mais bon
il a 7 secondes contre 21
non mais c'est vraiment un troisième
match c'est obligé enfin même si ce
match là est fini moi je suis je te je
suis
folie
je suis très heureux
quoi si c'est le cas comment on est le
CO2 dans sa pièce
après 6 heures de jeu
[Musique]
tu sens qu'il peut
que ça peut non
ah ça dégoûte
il est en train de gagner sa vie
du coup malheureusement je crois qu'il y
aura pas de
nouveau match alors fou j'ai 5 jouets
en même temps
les mauvaises nouvelles s'enchaînent
qui va perdre mais en fait c'est
vraiment un match supplémentaire là
c'est tellement écoeurant ça se coupe
[Musique]
la soirée j'ai peur que les mauvaises
nouvelles s'enchaînent
encore un côté Fabiano
non non mais il y a peut-être un
c'est vraiment fini leur match j'ai peur
que oui
on vous tient au courant quand même
cette division
très très mauvaise nouvelle les amis
ça peut être un club de fin cette partie
la deuxième division s'arrête
ça va être compliqué
sa cam pour qu'on puisse recadrer
peut pas le faire là pour le moment
parce que ça va rechanger d'ici
qui a l'air athée
donc il y a des quatre qui arrivait à ça
sans oh là là quelle mauvaise passe
on est mal il y a tout qui s'écroule là
sur ce stream
pour la régie qui n'avait pas allumé sa
cam pendant qu'il jouait et maintenant
que c'est fini il l'allume et il menace
de l'enlever
[Musique]
victoire de carwana et si un gars avait
gagné la dernière partie peut-être qu'on
se dirigeait vers un autre match
jusqu'au bout de la nuit
et là malheureusement donc la Ligue 2
est finie car on a l'emporte bravo à lui
d'ailleurs et du coup si là il garde pas
ben on aura plus de match à vous montrer
ce sera la fin du tournoi alors que si
caru gagne et qui gagne l'Armageddon
dans un deuxième match en quatre parties
on revie quoi
ça c'est ce qu'on espère mais j'ai
l'impression que ça va être compliqué
quand même compliqué
c'est un c'est des coûts qui sont assez
moches ça
les mauvaises nouvelles qui s'enchaînent
Fabien
et en fait en même temps c'est bizarre
que soit enterré dans
cette ouverture là
en fait il a jamais rien vu
non et en troisième division c'est qui
qui a gagné du coup au final je sais pas
ça je voulais pas aujourd'hui je crois
la troisième division
[Musique]
c'est Carlson le favorise pas du tout un
camera
il passe complètement à côté de sa
partie
peut-être trop déçu de celle d'avant et
là en plus si tu fais changer le four du
coup il va rester avec un mauvais fou
il est complètement pas ça à côté Kiko
ah ouais là je pense que la ouais il a
pas réussi à se mobiliser après la
déception de
de la partie précédente en fait
[Musique]
il est parti
parce qu'en fait ça a changé trop de
choses
là vous voyez qu'il est écœuré un Hikaru
ouais
c'est ça mais qui a gagné la 3e division
probablement
on voit
signe de lassitude côté ikaro
il est pas bien
et
puis voilà et qui est pénible parce
qu'il attaque 3 il est bien placé
il est très gênant
ça paraît difficile de voir Hikaru et
retourne la situation
ouais bon arriva défendre ça on l'entend
mais
on va gagner dur dur quoi
je pense qu'on puisse il est un peu
démissionner dans la tête là
et c'est compréhensible
il a raté une tellement grosse occasion
peut-être
un truc un peu irrationnel qui sort de
un instant
il se passe quoi si tu vois il est
obligé de quitter la partie comme ça
je donne partie à rejouer ou
tant pis
teur moins fort que Magnus parce qu'on
veut huit parties en fait nous enfin
10e match après que le meilleur gagne
mais là en fait
malheureusement
pas autant de parties qu'on aurait pu
ouais
en fait non plus
le temps si si mais enfin genre tu
insultes je me dis insultes après oui
être prétentieux ou arrogant ou quoi ça
bon tu vois enfin
ça j'ai pas j'ai pas contesté quoi
bizarre de passer par ici c'est pas
d'être en fait je comprends pas trop
mais tu pouvais passer par D3 gagner un
tempo sur la toit allant F4 oui bien sûr
[Musique]
il fait déjà très plaisir il a un truc
de dos
entre des supers
autre chose
bon après ouais c'est intéressant là il
me laisse vraiment qui j'ai 5 pour le
coup
complexe
de la saison
mais bon il y en aura d'autres ne vous
inquiétez pas vous êtes déçu que nous
aussi si vite
on remet le couvert dès le mois d'avril
ouais
en juillet
enfin août début ou non enfin je sais
plus je crois fin août à septembre et
surtout en décembre
un peu plus ça va enchaîner quasiment
tous les jours et ça ça va être vraiment
extraordinaire
c'était que qu'un
échauffement un échauffement qu'un
échantillon de c'est vraiment on peut
dire les six Grands Chelems de l'année
le super master à la fin une saison qui
va être
extraordinaire
quelque part demain
au milieu de ça quoi
qui prend des dates quoi presque
du championnat du monde est enfin non
mais favori ce tournoi non mais c'est
vrai
c'est vraiment le cas
ce circuit
forcément
carreau des goûters
un petit peu
j'ai la part une déco un truc comme ça
j'ai du mal à avoir une autre manière de
remporter ce match maintenant pour Ikao
il pourrait faire en deux matchs
gagnants la finale dans tous les cas
maintenant
le tableau de la petite finale
ce serait pas délirant qu'il est lui
aussi de vie quoi comme si
tu marques 10000 points tu regagnes
en battant saut
pour moi ce serait pas délirant que tu
récupères une vie en gagnant le looser
bracket je vois pas pourquoi tu en
aurais plus qu'une et que l'autre on
aurait deux
dans les bas-fonds du classement et
pourquoi il a qu'une ville autre en a
deux quoi
peut-être aussi des sports
truc comme ça peut-être une gaffe est si
vite arrivée aux échecs faut qu'il le
tende si Caro c'est bien vu de ta part
Fab
complexe
ouais dommage
au bout d'un moment ça peut échouer
tellement pourri tu as toujours un
problème
tu peux pas regagner une vie une fois
que tu es en looser avoir ça
ou une finale quand même peut-être qu'il
y a parti c'est un peu court
peut-être en 6108 en 12 je sais pas
ouais en tout cas on reste sur ah il y a
encore un truc qui est IBK c'est 5 à
nouveau le fameux
en tout cas sympa ce format et faudra
vérifier qu'il y ait bien 4 parties si
on avait gagné parce que ça pourrait
nous promettre de superbe final
la deuxième division nous a offert un
mano Amano extraordinaire entre karwana
et Yu-Gi qu'on aurait aimé voir en
première aussi
joli
cavalier et sur apprendre tours
il va probablement abandonner ici
mais il aura vraiment perdu le match
dans la partie précédente la chance en
fait
c'est vous que j'ai l'impression que
chaque coup de maïguste
il y a plus que ça
du coup vous jouez des coups qui attire
des coups ou nuisibles
il a pas perdu de tout le temps noir
Caro qu'il en porte très bien joué il
est il est un peu dégoûté on va pas
traîner ici pour que vous ayez la chance
de suivre les interviews après match
donc ben merci encore d'avoir suivi ce
tournoi ring donc qui était le sponsor
du tournoi qui a aidé les joueurs avoir
une bonne qualité d'air pour avoir des
bonnes parties et je propose qu'on se
qu'on se quitte sur le petit
et donc on vous dit à très bientôt dès
avril pour la suite de la compétition et
compétition sur cheesecom des Jeudis
prochain à pro de Chelsea pour nous à
16h30 merci à tous ciao ciao ciao